good evening
and good evening uh spectator
subscribers
viewers friends and others i'm douglas
murray
uh the associate editor at the spectator
in london
and it's an enormous pleasure uh to be
able to join
with so many of you this evening live
virtually but still live and
uh for this very special spectator event
i'd like to thank
natalie and all the events team for
being able to
uh bring this evening together and thank
all of you
first of all for joining us uh let me
say a very quick amount before i
introduce
our guest tonight a little bit of
housekeeping which uh
is necessary in this era as in any other
uh
um our guests and i are going to speak
for around 40 minutes
and then have time for about 20 minutes
of
questions and answers uh from uh you
at home and i've got a technical note
that i've got to
inform you all about which is that there
are two ways in which you can send in
questions this is very important
should should anything we say stimulate
you to
uh think of questions uh the first is
that you can type your question in the
text on the site now i'm told that this
is
this is extremely obvious um and i
suppose we'll see
but apparently there's a question you
can you can just type it on the site and
there's a clear
uh place to do that the other
possibility if if like me that sounds
slightly terrifying and not as obvious
as
it seems uh you can also
ask a question by emailing and you can
email events
spectator dot co dot uk that's events at
spectator.uko.uk
and i'll remind you of that later as
well just in case you're all being shy
and
no one sends in any questions but
without any further ado i'd like to talk
about briefly about our guests for this
evening a couple of years ago when our
editor at the spectator fraser nelson
asked if i would do the occasional event
and have some friends and uh
and people i uh admire to talk with
these events we had a first event an
amazing event some of you will remember
many of you have been at with roger
scrutin
uh in westminster we have another
available line of schreiber
and uh this event uh tonight i would
love to be able to do live
uh but it's it's as good as we can get
and it's going to be amazing
uh to be with uh our guest tonight
ayaan herciali needs i think very little
introduction
uh for most people she has a remarkable
life story she's
a remarkable woman i'm very proud to
have been able to call her a friend
for something coming on uh two decades
um she's written numerous books
including her
a life story in the best-selling books
infidel
and nomad she's most recently the author
of a new book called pray uh immigration
islam and the erosion of women's rights
and we're going to talk about that a bit
tonight but without funny uh any further
ado
i just want to be able to say welcome to
ayan
on behalf of all of us at the spectator
and what an enormous pleasure it is to
see you
it's a great pleasure to see you uh
douglas wonderful to be with you
unfortunately it's virtual but we'll
correct for that soon
we will indeed so let's let's start off
there's a lot that we can cover tonight
um but let's start off with prey um
i remember uh some time ago when you you
you mentioned to me that you were
thinking of doing a book in this area
and i remember
um making a whistling like noise i think
because i thought i've always admired
your ability to
go where uh angels fear to tread
um but this this really struck me from
the moment you mentioned it as
as as really treading into the one of
the most
difficult contentious argued over
subjects imaginable so that you could
just lay out a little bit about what the
book's about and then
how you decided to write it and and what
what kicked you off
well i mean i honestly have to say i
wasn't ready for a controversy and i'm
not
uh and i didn't write this book with the
intention
of uh inciting a controversy
but generating a conversation about
something very important that's going on
and you're absolutely right when it
comes to the issues of immigration islam
and women's rights all of these issues
are volatile
people are feel very passionately about
these things and generally
there is a sense that it's best to avoid
these
topics um but the subject of prey
is that women in europe in the public
space
and when i talk about women i'm talking
about all women not just
immigrant women or local women all of
them
have seen an increase in their safety in
the public space which is very different
from the private space
and this is an increase
of violence against women sexual
violence
and a lot of this is perpetrated by
immigrant men
and that is why the topic is
it's you know volatile taboo because
you're just having any kind of
conversation about immigration is just
hard enough uh and then on top of that
most of these immigrant men come from
muslim majority countries
where they have different attitudes to
women and
when you have all of that together and
there were events
in different parts of europe mainly in
germany in austria but also in sweden
in denmark in france and obviously also
in the united kingdom
i was reading a lot of anecdotal
evidence
on the media social media um
a friend of mine went and did a deep
dive
investigative journalism type of story
in austria
and she concluded she came away with oh
most of the perpetrators are from
afghanistan and this is something
that's happening in austria and i
thought no no no no
it's happening everywhere and it's not
just men from afghanistan it's men from
iraq and syria from somali from eritrea
from nigeria from ghana
and it's it's very important if we want
the immigration process and especially
the integration process to succeed
to address some of the negative and
unintended consequences
and that's why i did this book i mean
there are several things that i want to
ask about this because
one is of course you immediately enter
among other things
a statistical and evidential nightmare
uh because uh it seems to me i mean you
and you tread it with enormous
aplomb in the book um you're actually
dealing with an issue
in prey that every european
government is trying not to find out
about
uh so you know as you know that
the stats that you find are effectively
hidden away in the data
um the evidence isn't collected it seems
you know you have to go and dig for
yourself about it
how did you go about all of that
well first of all obviously i started by
calling the formal agencies government
agencies whose job
it is to collect this data so various uh
parts of the ministries of justice and
ministries in the interior
and many of them are very quick to say
yes we do have data on sexual violence
but we don't collect any kind of data on
ethnicity on religion country of origin
nationality
all of these features we just can't do
it and
in some cases on an informal way they
would say that has to do with
the history of for instance germany and
the second world war and the experience
of the jews and uh
because of that type of systemic and
systematic persecution that led to the
holocaust
we we just simply don't collect that
data so i thought okay
maybe i'll get it from the newspapers
and some of the
mainstream uh editorial newspapers tvs
and so on
they said that they had press norms
that were imposed on them on on the
journalists
doing the reporting to say you know a
man of
asian origin or of middle eastern
and that's what they used to write but
now they don't even write that anymore
so they would just
write the first name of the perpetrator
or the person of the suspect
and have an initial as the last name
but honestly even with the fast names
it's quite clear
where when a name is local and when a
name is foreign
um but aside from that i also started
having interviews i looked
for court cases i looked for victims and
had interviews with them and then i
started talking to the local people
and i found not every country is the
same in some countries they do actually
collect data and have gone
some of these governments have decided
that it wasn't
worthwhile to hide
this information from the public uh
denmark
is one such country but also austria
because of just a sheer number of
attacks that they've had to deal with
so everything that i have found i
document
in pray and when you read pray you're
not going to walk away
with a causal relationships here i'm
trying to be very
very careful but you do have a very
clear correlation
um and you know as you go
through the pages you're going to see
that every institution
is trying to find the right way for this
but
has either been good or bad mostly bad
uh
for a reason for instance if you take
the institution of
media they're damned if they report
because they're accused of empowering
the far-right and populist parties
but they're also damned if they don't
because if they don't
then they end up you know as
as citizens you end up going
to social media for your news or
unreliable news sources as well
unreliable news sources that
tell lies or exaggerate the issue so in
any case
that is the challenge for the media i've
spoken to members of the various police
forces and they would say they would
love nothing more
than to just do their job but very often
they're told by senior officials to drop
a case or not to investigate or not to
write down
the names and and that in that sense
they find that they're letting down
the victims and then you have the entire
court system which really wasn't
designed
for this type of thing for a
heterogeneous
society where people would be coming
from broken down societies
uh where violence is uh the threshold
for violence is law
so i mean
very often i've been asked well we admit
that there is a problem yes we have a
rise
of sexual violence against women and we
know that it's perpetrated mostly by
immigrant men but what would you like us
to do
and so there's this shrugging it off of
we've got to live with it
and an effect of that has been that for
many women especially in working-class
neighborhoods because that's where
the negative effects of immigration is
felt the most it is in working-class
neighborhoods working-class
places some of these women have decided
to act like the women in the countries
of origin where
they decide to think twice about whether
to go out in the first place
and what to wear whether they should go
up in larger numbers some of them have
been buying pepper spray and
trying to arm themselves in various ways
but their freedom of movement
is constrained and their safety is
limited and that is wrong it's not just
an erosion of women's rights it's an
erosion of the rule of law i mean it's
an extraordinary thing that this
this where um such an extraordinary
event can be constantly happening and
every agency
in the country including the media gets
stuck in this sort of
um impossible situation it seems to be
in their eyes i remember when i was
when i was researching the strange death
of europe uh in germany in 2015 and 2016
uh i remember speaking to germany and
said to me you know we
we think that whenever well the first
thing was they said
the whole thing about using asian as the
term was just
at the beginning was very confusing it
sort of suggested there was a sort of
chinese rape problem in parts of germany
which
you know maybe this term means different
things in different places and
and it seemed to be almost willfully
obfuscating
and then you had the problem was
described to me that if you didn't
describe anything about the ethnic
origin uh or the name
and you simply had as some uh some
particularly the german media would do
they sort of say well last night a thing
happened to a person in a place
and and people would actually just
assume that that must be a migrant
and in other words the less the press
tells the worse perhaps the population
think the things are because they're
having to read
the news through this filter of not
being told anything and coming to their
own conclusions
and that actually feeds into conspiracy
theories because people start to believe
anything
and uh if you look into the motives of
why some of these institutional leaders
are hiding or trying to obfuscate things
it's well intended it is to preserve
social cohesion
and it is to prevent prejudice against
immigrants because obviously not
all immigrants perpetrators of sexual
violence and not
all men from muslim majority countries
engage in this type of terrible behavior
but i think in many ways because of this
obfuscation
we just end up with exactly the opposite
effect
which is the breakdown of social
cohesion where
groups of different communities of
ethnic backgrounds and religious
backgrounds are constantly suspicious of
one another
and so i don't i really think it is
counterproductive and it's much better
to how to be very open and honest about
these things
but douglas as you know and i think
we're going to go into it
the backdrop for all of this in
the decade we live in now but also in
the previous decade and even the decade
before that is this emergence of
identity politics of looking at
individual citizens of various countries
not as individuals but as
members of different communities that
are supposed to be all seen by the
ideologues as hostile to one another
oppresses and oppressed
so i think this this is primarily the
reason
why we are having a lot of problems in
trying to
just bring into the open developments
within our societies that need urgent
attention and very often governmental
attention
but uh being ignored and and then these
problems just get bigger and bigger
and in these agencies i think they do
they're not held accountable you know
very well and i think the british public
knows the story
of the pakistani grooming gangs
if you if if early on 20 years or so ago
if the police the social workers
all the people whose job it was to
protect those children
had acted uh responsibly and had
helped and just done their jobs and had
helped these children
these young girls then i think we
wouldn't have had these
runaway networks and these men would not
be in prison and so
in hindsight you can see why the
decisions that were made to do nothing
actually were wrong and i don't know as
far as i can tell
but you maybe you can tell me this is
anyone in any of those institutions been
held accountable no they they they're
all
almost none or at least there's no
serious accountability
uh when operation bullfinch happened in
oxfordshire which i mean i mean there's
a sort of tendency as you know in the
sort of grooming gangs and rape gangs
discussion to sort of assume it only
happens in the north of england which is
itself a sort of excuse for not paying
attention
you know it's just places like rotherham
and rochdale it's sort of
dismissed by the particularly southern
uh um
uh media class so something happened
well operation bullfinch was in
oxfordshire it was a
grooming gang of immigrant men uh um
raping girls in the oxfordshire area and
after that came to light and the court
case and the convictions of a large
number of men
occurred um uh the the head of the
i think was child services at
oxfordshire district council
uh gave a video apology and you would
have thought she was
apologizing for sort of leaves on the
line in a train journey
no she said we we're very sorry for the
breakdown of services that occurred
in oxygen you're talking about a
situation where for instance
girls tried to escape men who were gang
raping them
got back to the the hostily way they
were in
and were sent back to the gangs because
the people in charge of the hostel
wouldn't pay the taxi fare
you know that was just one of the
stories from it that you know about it
absolutely horrific
and to hear the uh um one of the people
responsible for this
just outrage uh um giving this sort of
pathetic bureaucratees apology really
was one of the things that made me most
angry about this
before before we move on by the way to
the identity politics let me just
raise a couple other things quickly
which is i think the identity of the
victims
is a very important thing in this as
well because as it were the identity
politics of talking about the
perpetrators is one thing
but there seems to be a sort of issue
about the identity of the victims in
these cases the women
in cologne uh from new year's eve
um and particularly the the well it
turns out thousands
of victims in towns across england
um you just tell us something about that
because it's very striking to me i just
thought you do they just throw out one
other story which is
uh um some years ago i remember mark
stein told me he was thinking about
writing a book in
in in this area and and um
actually it was such a depressing
subject to look into he just sort of
couldn't bear it my other finger
you know um but he said one thing that
always haunted me on this he said
as he went round england speaking to
some of the girls who were the victims
he had the impression that they would be
sort of talked out you know the
rotherham victims the rochester victims
the telford victims
and he said it it was quite the opposite
uh they they kept telling him things
like you're the first person who's come
and asked me what happened you're the
first journalist i've spoken to
and i always thought that was that was
so haunting and shaming
that that would be the case but the
identity of the victim
seems to be a major component
um i i have found that also in different
countries that's uh the identity of the
victims in this case so i'm
in in the book it's a documenting of
sexual violence against what they call
strangers
so the perpetrator and the victim do not
know one another it's
random and some of the perpetrators act
as individuals but very often as groups
of
two three four or more and there are two
things that strike me
and struck me about the identity of the
victims
one is the prejudice that the
perpetrators
hold against white girls
they deem them to be in
indecent uh not virtuous not modest
and up for grabs so that is the
prejudice that
the immigrant men who engage in this
in these sexual violence acts they have
that prejudice against these girls
the other type of prejudice is class
and i know that in the uk
it's much more common to talk about
class differences
but in many european countries there is
a sense that oh we are
so equal and egalitarian we have
absolutely
no class issue i think that is a lie
because
indeed if the victim happens to be a
girl of middle class where the
parents educate have a college education
university education
and or a higher income the outrage
generally seems to be
more widespread it's carried by the
newspapers and television stations and
so on and then
local officials law enforcement and
government officials are forced
to do something about the problem or
pretend to do something about the
problem
but when it is in working-class
neighborhoods and again i repeat
they do carry the biggest burden when it
comes to the negative
and unintended consequences of
immigration it is
that class factor is one that has to be
looked into
and uh what i also thought was
fascinating was
anywhere where there is any kind of
feminism you know
organized groups of women who say that
they
are there to fight for the rights of
women
this is mostly middle class it's mostly
about
getting women into positions of power uh
on boards
uh shattering ceiling um
finding some kind of balance between
home life and working life
those are the priorities it's not the
priorities
of safety in the public space in
working-class neighborhoods and
transport hubs and that sort of thing so
yes this is
very much a class issue here that's not
been looked into
and yes yes that's such a fascinating
point i am because
uh i i think the historians would look
back on this era and think you know
what were the feminists uh um
campaigning about most vociferously in
that era
and if you notice there's a vast number
of cases you talk about in your book
across europe the way in which there
seem to be an ignoring of the problem or
just an unfamiliarity a best and
unfamiliarity with the problem
it strikes me as something that people
are going to look back with bafflement
and what's more as you well know if you
bring out him pray
in an era where where in every other
situation
claiming that a woman was as it were
asking for it
yeah is completely unacceptable
for a brief period yes it was the case
that as a woman you are not held
responsible for the misconduct of the
male perpetrator in europe in the united
states of america at least that was a
milestone that feminists had reached
which was doesn't matter what she's
wearing it doesn't matter whether she's
drunk or not it doesn't matter if she's
in the wrong place you are not supposed
to commit the crime
and here uh in the stories that i tell
in uh pray these women
have all said the exact same thing no
one actually listens to them
at all and very often these victims
would say to me
i want to tell you my story but before i
tell you my story i want to make it very
clear
that i'm not political i have no
right-wing connections in fact i've
always voted for
social democrats or center-left parties
and
i want immigrants to come here and i
want them to flourish i want them to
thrive i just wanted them to stop this
crime
this is what the victims are saying now
when it comes to social democratic
parties
center-left parties i think they have
abandoned their constituencies
and these women are in fact their
constituencies and
these women have nowhere to go at this
point and the only
i think the only way out would be for
them
the women themselves to start forming
their own organizations
and interestingly the only other group
of women
who were very very vocal about this
issue were immigrant women
survivors of honor violence and
survivors
of uh you know women who felt that their
families were imposing
islamist views on them to cover
themselves and stay at home and
marry someone that they didn't want
according to women who survived these
things in the various countries while
the women's were out
in front saying look what's happening
the more you bring men from muslim
majority countries the more
our neighborhoods are affected the
social control is more severe
and are seeing these problems almost
like it's
back home from the countries you know
from north africa or the middle east
of asia or uh various parts of africa so
i think that there there is an
opportunity perhaps for
working-class women and immigrant women
to form some kind of movement
and fight this because i don't think
these uh center-left parties are
interested
in in their in their interests anymore
these parties are now driven by identity
politics so it's
things that like skin color as you know
and religion and islamophobia
and other you know very trendy sounding
causes well let's get on to that because
um i i regard you as being
one of the most acute observers as well
as one of the bravest observers
of the scene in the west in particular
perhaps at the moment
and um and i wondered you know having
followed your career very closely for
many years i wondered what you think
now looking out at the situation in in
america
in britain across europe um you've got a
great eagle eye for spotting the things
that
people aren't daring to talk about but
should
uh um what are the one what are the ones
that are on your mind at the moment
well to be honest with you it is what
everyone has now been talking about for
quite some time
which i i was not in the least
evil eye towards i in fact dismissed
uh council culture critical race theory
critical justice theory all this
identity politics stuff
you know a while i dismissed it as as a
fad
and i thought it was something that was
just in universities and as soon as
these students graduated and
got in touch with the real world that
they would shed them
because the real world would teach them
i didn't expect this thing to expand
out of these colleges and into the wider
society into corporations the government
everywhere else but i do see
um that there are these connections
where you know if you ignore the
constraining of free speech and academic
freedom
in the universities and then you ignore
it again
or you succumb to it you submit to it
in elementary and high school education
and then right now what we are seeing in
the united states is that the government
itself various governmental departments
are imposing
this critical race theory
features on employees and government
employees
and the same is happening with
corporations
i think in in the long run it's very
easy to see
how you know the the minds of americans
can be closed
and i wanted to ask you in fact i know
that there is a similar struggle going
on in the uk perhaps not as dramatic as
here in
in the us but i i wanted to ask you
how is it in the uk because we are in a
very very bad position here in america
from what i can see yeah i think you're
certainly right about that i mean i
spend a certain amount of my time there
in america and
notice these these trends there i mean
it's odd isn't it the way that
these sorts of um um these things
hesitate to use the term virus about
this but these sort of thought viruses
sort of transfer between the continents
it seems to me now and there are certain
things that
we know well about in europe about for
instance islamist extremism which
america is sort of a bit behind on some
of it i would say
um but then you get the things like the
uh
the sort of um council culture uh
the term identically like but also you
know obviously the identity politics
of the critical race theory and more and
that that's just flooded out of america
straight to the uk and elsewhere readers
of the spectator
well now i mentioned some of this in my
column this week
where um you know institution after
institution
keeps deciding that since the death of
george floyd at the hands of a
minnesotan policeman who's now in prison
uh they have to change everything about
their institution
you know whether it's the the national
trust or
the uh or norwich town hall last week or
uh
everyone's got kew gardens recently
announced that uh
that uh botanical uh gardens were uh
um racist um uh
and and then we had the royal academy of
music the other day
it's denied it since but it said it was
going to decolonize its instrument
collection it's collection of ancient
instruments
as i said in spectator i think george
floyd would be surprised to have heard
that his killing was going to lead to a
purge of harpsichords in london but but
it seems to have just washed across the
entire culture
it's a fascinating thing that and um but
america is the absolute
um source of this it's um
it's patient zero on this and it is
stunning to me
the speed with which it's spilled out
but you see you've seen uh
you've seen this up close well yes
first if you go you know to the roots of
it these post-modernist
philosophers came from france and then i
think
they were cultivated here in various
american universities
in places where they they have gender
studies and race studies and all sorts
of
uh you know other seemingly innocent
uh things that people want to focus on
or in some cases i mean i looked at
gender studies and i always think
when you have a degree in gender studies
what are you going to do
afterwards but so it seemed
kind of contained and eccentric
in these places but now it's become
it's a big deal and i think the
the um the effects that we're seeing
is it's caused by groups like
the strident inflexible transgender
activists
where of course it's very understandable
that they say they want equal rights for
transgender people and they want these
people to be recognized which is one
thing
but when there are unintended
consequences
like young children being lured through
the internet
into undergoing physiological changes
that are dramatic
and you know cannot be reversed and we
can't have a conversation about that
when the healthcare professionals are
too terrified and just go along with
that
women's presence now uh you know we have
just passed the law in california and
this just tells you how crazy things are
that if you you don't have to undergo
any kind of process
to become female or male you just have
to say i
identify as such and so male
prisoners male convicts
are claiming to be female and no one is
allowed to ask any question they're
being housed with women
and uh here now these men are being
abusive towards these women and no one
is listening to these women
you know we are seeing things like that
we're seeing
the entire education system where
children
as young as six or seven or eight years
old
are being told if they're white that
they're oppressors
which in my book is just pure child
abuse because why
not would you be telling a six year old
seven eight nine year eight nine year
old that they're oppressors and they're
responsible for all these
heavy history and then uh the children
of color are being told that they're
victims
and again in its own way that's also a
form of abuse because these children are
being told they have no
agency everything that happens to them
that is negative is
as a consequence of something that white
people do
and this is now becoming the standard
curriculum and so i'm seeing around
a lot of parents who are saying that
they're either going to leave the
country or home school
or start their own schools um and then
in government people are being subjected
to these
so-called mandatory uh
unconscious bias trainings uh and this
is just
really an ideological indoctrination and
the policing of what people think
and so here it's it's crazy it's it's
going out of control let me let me ask
you a couple of things before before we
bring in uh
audience questions and just remind the
audience so these two two techniques for
sending in questions uh one of them is
to
send it in on apparently the extremely
obvious box on your screen
and the other is to email events at
spectator.com
uk uh before we get to audience
questions there is just a couple of
things
the first is um i'd love your thoughts
on this what do you what do you make of
this and it
touches on on on a number of things we
have to spoke about what do you make of
the way in which
um identity seems to be sort of
transferable depending
not just on the identity of the speaker
but on the specific words they
use so that for instance
um some people who are not white
are allowed to voice their opinions and
indeed to tell everyone to listen
and other people who happen not to be
white are told to shut up
because they're not saying helpful
things in some ways
and this seems to have been rife in
america i wonder if you've got any views
on that
um it's and it's not just in america it
has now also come to europe yes but
if you are black or of you know indian
origin or
if you're non-white yes it seems
that at first what you say
if it diverges from the ideology
people might listen but after that
really
douglas even then you're dismissed as
you know i i'm a proponent of the free
market
obviously with protections of the
unintended consequences of the free
market um
i believe in individual freedom and
individual responsibility and
accountability
these things are now called whiteness
and racist
i believe that people should actually
try and pick themselves up by their
bootstraps first
if possible and only afterwards ask for
help all of these things are now
regarded as
whiteness we are told that punctuality
is whiteness
that mathematics objective truth is
whiteness
and there are obviously a lot of people
who are not white who object to that and
say
it's just absurd and what does that mean
what does that make me as
as black person or person of color does
that make me is it just
i'm lazy i can't read the time i can't
plan for the future
my merit is to be questioned only
because of my skin color so you see how
it's
sort of a subtle racism that goes on
yeah
but if you're sorry guys
i was gonna ask one other follow-on from
that before i come to some excellent
audience questions coming in perhaps you
can help me with
one question i've already had in recent
years about this is why can you now
predict with 100
certainty uh uh the views that a certain
type of public figure is going to have
uh on a range of issues i think let me
give you throw two examples out there
um ilan omar a famous uh congresswoman i
think from somalia i think originally
isn't she yes
when she was in office of a very brief
amount of time wrote
to the local sports authorities in her
district complaining
that they wouldn't allow somebody was
born a man
to win the women's weightlifting
competition uh
and in no ordinary way would i you
expect ilan omar who
holds pretty strict views uh her islamic
background
to be standing up for the big bearded
man winning the women's weightlifting
competition but there it is
and the second example springs to mind
is um aoc
another famous um
young congresswoman who um in her first
weeks in office did a fundraiser for the
very very controversial charity mermaids
which seeks to
help children in the uk transition you
think why would aoc
be interested in in raising thousands of
pounds
for a children transitioning
group in the uk well that's because it's
part of the ideology and i don't know
when at one point at what point
uh these internal contradictions are
going to come about
but in the case of ilhan omar
there's the the islamists and the
uh the woke ideologues are united in the
hate
of america in the hate of individualism
in the hate of accountability in the
hate of israel
and in their anti-semitism and so in
many ways they they have
common ground in all of these things
now aoc and high interest in the
transgender community
i don't know i don't know much about
that but i do know that
part of this um you know the erasing
of sex
and gender it's part of the work
ideology there are no women there are no
men it's all fluid they're 100
genders or more i mean i sometimes ask
why stop at 100 you could just say
a hundred somewhat limiting if you think
about it yeah
these are some of the you know ten
commandments or whatever they're
religious orthodoxy
ideological you know ideological
orthodoxy so i do
see where they see common ground but i
think it is for us on the outside
to poke at their contradictions and to
demand really
uh you know if you're a proponent of
sharia
and then what are your views on the
rights of women
and all on the lgbt community on a
jewish community and so it's for the
outsiders
uh to keep asking these questions but
unfortunately they do not want to debate
coleman hughes who is a friend and a
black man he invited ibram ex
who's one of the living prophets of this
this critical race theory i call it now
criminal race theory
and he he invited ibrahim x kennedy to
debate he will not
respond i did robin d'angelo to come and
debate with me she will not
they will not debate because they are
not ready to defend
their beliefs and their ideas they just
want to impose it on others and that
really really
makes them into much more of a religious
movement
than a political movement yeah well i i
have to say um
i think i know why they won't i know
coleman and and i know why ibra makes
candy won't debate him which is that
coleman would make mince meat of candy
and i know why robin d'angelo won't
debate you which is you
may miss me to her so so on a personal
uh career level they're very sensible to
keep away
and uh typically disingenuous of them to
do so
let's go to some questions i've got a
lot of them have come in uh um
here's a very interesting one from amir
um is there any other option
amir asks than either government and law
enforcement doing what we pay them to do
or a tommy robinson persona leading the
charge against predators
well in my book i think that law
enforcement
should do their job because you know we
have governments
that have the monopoly of violence and
we pay taxes first and foremost so that
the government can protect
its citizens from external forces and
also from
domestic harm and so i think it is
key very important that we do hold
government
accountable for that now the tony
robinsons of this world
ideally you would not want the tony
robinsons of this world to be the voice
of women's emancipation
but what you want is for those voices
where
you know where there is where there is
harm and and the individuals the victims
when they voice that harm you you want
them to be listened to
and they've always been in europe groups
and organizations and individuals that
articulate particular interests and we
touched on feminism
and the feminist movements and
organizations don't seem to be
interested
in this or in they may have made a
trade-off where they think it's
far more important to them to protect
the sentiments of the immigrant
community
rather than women's rights these are
these are
you know personal choices and
organizational choices that they've made
that are wrong
but as you said the question was posed
by a person called
anir i think it's also important that
individuals within the communities where
the perpetrators come from
should come forward and say we don't
want
the community name smeared and the way
to stop that from happening is not to
pretend that there's nothing going on
and be offended because we're talking
about the problems but to go after the
individuals who are the perpetrators who
are engaged in this terrible behavior
and stop them
let me throw another question in uh paul
asks uh
wokest mobs across the western world
have had great success
rewriting the basic tenets of our
established history
what are the key factors at work that
have made such inroads into our
established historical legacy and what
does it say about historians
that they have had such an easy ride so
far now i hate to say but you're married
to a historian of course and
uh don't speak for him but this is a
very interesting question
it is a very interesting question and
yes i am married to a historian who is
very much upset by what's going on and
by this erosion of history
and i think part of it is because i we
took it for granted
that uh people who you know that these
things
have been fought and there's not only
anybody who's
fighting historians was going to lose
i think because there was a sense that
the history departments within
universities teaching of history in high
school and
elementary school that that was a given
that these curricula were not
controversial at all and that's one and
i think when
we saw the first signs of opposition
many people ignored that development
including historians and i think
historians should take responsibility
for that
um a lot of these um institutions were
underfunded
and then there was this ideological bent
where people on the left and
perhaps even on the far left were
left to do the administration and
you know to recruit academics so that i
i don't know very much about the uk
because i didn't look into it but in the
united states
almost all things that colleges and
universities do
uh is done by the left i think it was
michael bloomberg who remarked on it
sometime in 2014
15 where he said something you know it
was over 95
or 98 percent of professors at harvard
and most of the ivy league
had given to the democratic party and so
in that sense you see this ideological
bent
and lack of balance and so all of these
things it
it i mean i think we're just seeing the
sudden change but these things were
going on for quite some time
then i think we we confused uh critical
thinking
with self-condemnation it's very good to
look
critically at the history of western
civilization and of the various
countries within western civilization
but it is wrong to condemn it
wholeheartedly and to say you know the
whole thing has just been really awful
and
it's only a story of oppression slavery
and exploitation when in fact that's not
the case
uh the history of western civilization
is also the story of
civilization and emancipation the
emancipation of women
the emancipation of and the abolition of
slavery
and this quests relentless quest for
equal rights for everyone so i think
that story has to be told
before these very naughty people tell us
and
that walkism is the way out by the way
i'll just add one coder to that if i may
which is there's also a technical reason
it seems to me in the teaching of
history
which is that uh uh issues like for
instance empire
uh were unpopular for some time
in um in academic study in the uk for
instance
uh it was almost as if there was a
realm of knowledge that was that was
forgotten uh
so much so that when for instance you
had the rosemary's fall campaign at
oxford
the campaigners were saying things that
cecil rhodes had said which he just
hadn't said
you know there are all sorts of
legitimate claims you can make for and
against cecil rhodes but they were just
making stuff up and no one seemed to
notice
until nigel biger of of church college
looked into it did what anyone should do
and you know read the
dictionary of national biography entry
to start with on cecil rhodes and
founder
so it's a very interesting thing that
that effectively the
the campaigners and others the defamers
are speaking into a kind of knowledge
vacuum
where we have a sort of forgotten
knowledge or forgotten history
uh which perhaps perhaps needs to be dug
up again
this goes to a number of the questions
um that are coming in
uh let me this is jumping around
slightly there's a
fair amount about history which is very
interesting but maybe we could also go
to
helena who asks why are immigrant women
living in europe not fighting this
erosion of rights
first of all is helena wright and why is
it yes
so to helena there are actually a lot of
immigrant women who are fighting it
and i think i said before during our
first conversation that
in fact surprisingly it is immigrant
women
who have lived in europe for a number of
years some of them who were born and
raised in europe
who are seeing some of these changes and
are fighting it
but they are not large enough and
they're not powerful enough they don't
have the resources
but aside from that you immigrant women
especially those from
muslim households have to deal with the
culture at home
where as girls they're pulled out of
school
they're subjected to all of these
scriptures
around honor uh you're not allowed to
wear makeup you're not allowed to have a
boyfriend you're not allowed to finish
school you're not allowed to work you're
forced into marriage all of these things
and the bigger and more conservative or
reactionary
that community is the more of a
constraint that there is for girls and
women so it is
really really tough on immigrant women
in particular
to come out because they don't they they
have to fight the
woke ideology that's trying to label
them victim
when some of them are really proud
survivors
and and want what everyone else wants to
have
and then you also have as an immigrant
you have to deal with your family your
extended family your community
that are telling you that you're
becoming too westernized
too british or too american or too
swedish or what have you
and so it's a very good question but
it's
i think these women are not seen enough
and not heard enough
um let's go probably got time for a
couple more questions
so do keep sending them in um
this is a this is one uh i think you're
very well placed
to uh to answer ayanna oliver says in
this
i think this is said slightly cheekily i
must say he says in the spirit of
balance
do we need to talk more about the
slavery that took place in other
parts of the world absolutely please
let's do it and it's not
you said took there is slavery that
still takes place
uh today in the middle east in south
asia in africa where i come from there
are people when i was
growing up in somalia who was somali
at least seen within the nation states
whatever is left of it
somalia but these people were forced
into labor
and they were not paid and they were
called slaves
when i lived in saudi arabia just
because of my black skin
saudis referred to me and my family
members are slaves they still do
there are all sorts of people who go
immigrants who go from
various parts of africa and asia to work
in the middle east and those people are
treated very very poorly close almost
closely they're not sold and bought but
they're not paid what's due to them and
very often they find that they can't
leave those circumstances
look at human trafficking uh look at uh
the whole sex industry i mean they all
depend on people who actually can't get
out
and are forced to do jobs that are awful
and that they can't they didn't ask for
so instead of you know being mesmerized
and
hyper focused on the slavery of
200 years ago why don't we talk about
the slavery that's going on
now and then again i want to point out
actually it is western civilization it
is
the british and the americans who fought
was to end
slavery and who told the story over and
over again
of why human dignity must stand above
uh you know religious and ideological
notions
of inferiority that you know you might
hold towards other people
and so that story hasn't been told and
it should be told and it can't
you can't really understand it if we're
not honest about
the history itself i'm not surprised
that people are asking quite a number of
people are asking about history
i really hope that you know a large
number
large enough number of british people
and others
stand up and demand that history be
you know be taught and be taught right
and and be told honestly
we've got time for perhaps one final
question before we do can i just throw
in one of my own as well i and i'd
love to know your answer to this uh
before we go to a final question from
the audience in the remaining few
minutes we have
um we've been living through he hasn't
come up this evening
um but uh we've been living through all
of us the most
extraordinary and unusual period in the
last 18 months or so
it's obviously too early to tell in lots
of ways but
do you have any views on on how us all
being forced into our solitude
for well over a year in this
unprecedented situation
will affect some of the issues we're
talking about tonight
and if there's other things you see
coming down the road as a consequence of
this extraordinary time
well i think the the main question in
free societies
is you know how much power do we hand
government
and then what do governments do with
that and governments have to balance
between you know respecting
personal liberty and all the other
liberties that
have but also containing this disease
and understanding it and i think in
every country
western country you see those
conversations being had
um what kind of effect is this going to
have on the conversations that we've
been having for instance
immigration and the negative
consequences of immigration
but especially the integration of
immigrants
into the wider society and what's the
role of government in that
and if government does take upon itself
that role
then how much of the individual freedoms
of immigrants who are to be integrated
is going to be sacrificed in the name of
that higher good
of you know the outcome so i think it's
we're living in very very interesting
times but i it's
legitimate both to say you know we we
don't want government compromising our
liberty
we also you know don't want the economic
the economies to be collateral damage
but at the same time these governments
do have to understand
um and and encounter
such things as the pandemic if you
you said that i liked uh controversial
issues but
i think for instance just looking back
at your country
do you think in hindsight that
an organization like the nhs
should have been saddled with this
particular emergency
but then you're not allowed to ask such
questions because the nhs is now
sacred and so you know everything goes
back to
uh what can we talk about
[Music]
honest conversations of ours yeah let me
wrap up there's a couple of questions uh
linked
um we both have a shot at them um mata
asks is the only way forward to speak
the truth in our everyday lives
rather than using their ideology against
the woke
and uh then um sophie says
douglas and diane you have oh there's a
very nice question another flash right
she says you have helped keep us sane
through this culture war madness
what do you suggest we do okay you go
first diane
let me go with number one and say
because
uh the critical race theory movement
critical justice still social warriors
their movement
one of the key objectives is to pollute
our language to contaminate the everyday
language that we speak to one another
so obviously the most glaring
pushback or
answer to that would be not to allow
them to do that so that we just
speak plain english and if english is a
second language in my case it's
a fourth language you've worked very
hard to know to understand and you're
taught
grammar and syntax and all that and
suddenly they come around and they
introduce this incredibly
ugly vocabulary and so you have to learn
their language and i think
language is
especially the english language is one
of the
realms that we have to protect
from these people it's the only way to
have honest debates
discussions and conversations
and let's not allow them let's not speak
their language
very clearly yes there are men and women
not people who menstruate or
all of these adding the letter x to
nouns it's
just terrible don't allow them to do
that just speak plain english
the plainer the simpler the better
there's nothing
quite like making you feel smaller than
i am reminding you that
she's speaking in her fourth language
i didn't mean to do it but you know how
no no no i know
i know but it is one of the things it's
been remarkable i mean
you arrived in holland and you you learn
dutch immediately
sort of anyhow uh something one of the
many things i've always admired about
you let me just a very
quick stab at sophie's question i think
i i agree with everything ayan just said
and i think
i think everyone has a role in their
everyday lives in order just not to as
it says not to fall into the
the traps that are laid for us uh i've
come to the view that
that you shouldn't demand kamikaze like
acts of bravery from
everyone but we can all speak up a bit
more
we can all take a bit of a step forward
there are cases i am there as well from
america in particular
where just individual parents for
instance have said no
no not having this at this school when
i'm not having you teach my children
this junk
uh this racist divisive nonsense and and
it has a huge effect and
and they must be onto something because
they get so when you know individual
parents
uh stand up like that they get huge
attention and if they were on to nothing
no one would care uh it's because
they're on to a thing that so many
people
feel a majority feel i believe but too
few people speak up
about that's the reason why there is so
much attention but but if there was more
of that and i
i think there will be then i think these
are
these are winnable battles uh i may have
said before doyle i mean i i
i fought many unwinnable battles in my
life i'm an expert in them
uh connoisseur you might say but uh i
it means i know i know a winnable battle
when i see one and i i think
i think uh on on much of this it's a
winnable battle
um now i am we we started four or five
minutes later
we're we're um we just passed the hour
uh here
um that there's so much more we could
talk about
and so much more i know that everybody
with us this evening
would love to hear about and so much
more i would like to hear about
uh will you promise me one thing before
we finish which is that whenever we're
all allowed out of our seclusion
and we're allowed to take the risk of
sitting next to other spectator
subscribers in a
theater and more than 30 people do you
promise you can come back and do this in
a
in real life in real time in real person
i promise to do that
and i promise to do it in the uk
fantastic
i'm gonna hold you to that promise i
hope that everybody who's joined us
tonight
uh will hold us to that promise um
thank you everybody uh for joining us
this evening thank you again
uh to the events team at the spectator
uh most of all thank you ayan it's been
a thrill as ever
uh to see you i can't wait till that
next opportunity
and until then thank you and
to everyone thank you and good night
you